on new shake brings all the girls hey
[Music]
what's up guys I'm Q Blake hi I'm Karen
and I'm Connie and today we gonna guess
where these milkshakes off from shake it
up y'all to be honest right now Oh No
one time in high school we decided it
would be the summer of milkshakes and
what we did is we went to every
fast-food place in our small town and we
had every milkshake from there so I feel
pretty confident we can do this yeah I
think so too
okay so first off this is the only one
of our entries that comes with a cherry
so somebody's trying to bribe us already
and I think that that's a little dose of
whipped cream on top too so that's a
clue okay so that's a clue that's a clue
it's a clue this strawberry I don't
wanna dream a milkshake with me man
[Music]
mmm that's delicious I'm so good guys
it's so good it's amazing whoa anybody's
double-dip your strawberry think about
that see this is like that it's
definitely chick-fil-a it's got a clean
flavor profile as of right now I'll say
this one is chick-fil-a I was gonna go
McDonald's yeah
yeah I feel like with the way the cream
is in it but that's off of a visual
I feel like didn't like the way that
like it mixes it looks like a McDonald's
yeah I didn't think this was gonna be
this hard
let's go for a second one these flavors
are messing me up we should have got all
one flavor it's a new walk in the park
okay I think immediately this one is the
frosty okay this one is a lot more it's
a lot sweeter oh yeah that's hot like I
have you guys something big chocolate
yeah wait no I got this job this time
I'm perfect oh my god frosty tickets are
frosty
oh no oh no I think that might be a
prostate
this one's chick-fil-a mmm I ain't
Burger King has whipped cream hmm Oh
does have a slight frosty ish taste it
might be Burger King - you think it
might be Burger King maybe there's
wasn't much more I would say taste
presents I feel like you're gonna
actually taste like I know that this one
is chock for sure but almost like a
little too much no I love it
really I wanted to keep me straight in
the taste buds it tastes great I'm gonna
say this was McDonald's I'm gonna say we
go shake the light okay away we're off
we're on we're not we're not together on
this yeah I'm not sure that's a good or
bad thing this is a hundred percent
windy that's why we grabbed this spoon
this is when need is not a question look
at that that's a frosty so you think
this one is the frosting yeah okay guy
you're so sure that this is Wendy this
is no no what if that's the Windies one
and you don't even know you don't even
know you're just so sure no you can tell
what a consistency like it doesn't sit
on my spoon like a frost he's gonna sit
on my spoon I think I might be
McDonald's know if this is McDonald's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm a hundred percent sure this is
Wendy's like you gotta trust me on this
number like if he never trust me before
in your life
today's a day all right I know I'm
frosting if I'm right on the rest of
them this year to be McDonald's and if
I'm right under s1 this one has to be
burger cake we're gonna go for the last
bus drop the final straw
oh that means this is burger you know
I'm like an expert Rome you talk like
you know I just did a double dip you
didn't that's where Donald's and I don't
like the consistency of this one is so
much Tejanos breath that's definitely
McDonald's just got that me it literally
tastes like McDonald's ice cream I hate
it I think this is me this day somebody
black McDonald's ice cream like you said
mmm-hmm that's McDonald this one I think
it's Burger King I think this one's
chick-fil-a okay I think this one is
chick-fil-a I think this one is Burger
King Wendy's Wendy's McDonald's my
selection is chick-fil-a Burger King
Wendy's McDonald's and my selection with
many reservations is the same and if
this is wrong it's completely your fault
uber will know that all right so first
one first one what is it
let's go you don't listen to me man it's
about quality yes okay great second one
what this is McDonald's
are you serious for dramatic effect are
you for real
no oh okay all right find out fight it
or you can still come out struck
okay but this is Wendy's this is
definitely one Dee's come on okay
sometimes I know I believed you on that
one but you led me astray over here you
led me astray hey you were so sure okay
so this is Burger King are you kidding
me yo okay so he messed up so I got
three out of four wrong that was
horrible I did horrible wait so what did
i do I got two out of four s like LeBron
trying to make the playoffs it was just
bad LeBron I do not support that
government at all
so these two were the ones that we
didn't go Wow okay that doesn't surprise
me
um because these were my least favorites
and I know that Burger King McDonald's
actually have my least favorite shakes
all jokes aside like I'm actually really
disappointed
I love milkshakes and there's no way
that I got this wrong like honestly I'm
not gonna blame myself and I won't point
any elbows uh who let me wrong yeah okay
we got these two wrong but I understand
that because they're just not the thing
I like the most
no so I I get that we got we've had
these more than these for sure
milkshake brought the zero girls to the
yard today this we're sorry mm
[Music]